we dead cuz we back at it again it's the
fighter in the kid this is really the
fighter in the kid come on baby hard to
take you serious when you look like that
right now
what I'm an animal flight the animal are
supposed to be this way but their backs
it looks like you're racing you're
little race deer race yeah I'm like that
I'm like I'm like oh that's exactly what
you're like yeah I'm like
Hermes yeah I like your sweater I like
your Christmas sweater where'd you get
that Christmas sweater bro this is
special dude Target's popping bro Target
I get my jeans from Target that's sad no
they're Levis well now I got sad they're
Levis 505 whatever they are you get
jeans from Target huh hell yeah dude
well I get my jeans from like places
like Rag and Bone you can spend 250
bucks or 40 bucks I don't know if
there's that much of a difference there
is no there's a difference in the cut
but hey in the cut for you but I my legs
are but I got a tricky body cuz my my
butt and my legs are bigger than my
waist so I can't get into those skinny
jeans you don't Skinny's out yeah but
but also like I would go to John vvos
and I would try on those skinny jeans
and I was like I'm not I don't have the
biggest legs but who's wearing these
things is that what it is some dudes
just have no no you got you got to be
built like Machine Gun Kelly to shop it
that's so weird yeah it's for guys with
no ass right and the guy in fact the guy
even said this was the best he goes well
you got this the greatest I can't I he
goes yeah you're not going to fit in
those CU you got those hockey player
legs and I wi
you go so you have a giant erection now
I had a huge erection and then a girl
goes um yeah those look like they're
hard for you to get into I go and I go
yeah well
Sports oh
no yes I wish I was Private little
[__] victories that I get I would
have went have you ever seen a hockey
player likes yeah but dude you've not
seen me give boxing lessons Jiu-Jitsu
I've seen it all seen that I've seen all
that dude when people I'm on the plane
and the guy first class uh I don't know
why I said that the point
is so obnox but you said it no but but
what I mean by that is that it's a it
was the the cabin was fairly small so
you can there was a curtain so you could
hear stuff so he he turns around and he
goes who do you got for the fight and
that's the wrong question because I'm a
fight expert Y and I went through the
whole Kobe Covington versus Leon Edwards
I went through the whole card shot you
messed that
up destroy and one thing I'm really good
at is when I he something I don't forget
it and I'll make it sound like it's my
idea you regurgitate what I said and
then well I got a lot of friends that I
check in with and I'm a plagiarist yep
and then I put it all together like a
collage and Brian sounds like a [__]
genius you mix a match it oh do I ever
do I ever I mean what are you doing for
the holidays buddy this is our last
episode of the Year man 2023 sum it up
in one word okay 2023
terrible hey hey hey the 2023 is 2023
2023 is the Titanic is is Phoenix the
Phoenix we're slowly rising from the be
2024 Bud yeah 2024 were Phoenix is 2024
look look 2023 2020 2023 looks was like
this 2023 it was like this and then it
was like this found out who we are found
out what we're made of 2023 was just
found out we're like we just you know
what sometimes we had a lot of drama we
had some money stolen from us when I say
some money I mean all the money ship you
don't know how well your ship's going to
do unless it goes right through a storm
and we we you got to battle test
everything it's quality control bro yeah
it's no different than what Dodge does
with those no demon 170s they test the
engine for three days straight at the
highest RPM to see what breaks down
that's it and then they fix the the rods
the Pistons that's what we are dude you
and I just kept showing couple hems we
kept showing up you went through your
adderal addiction your face with super
all bad stuff 2023 your boy had an
anoral addiction thing we had some drama
we had money stolen from us but what did
I say to you the other day what' I say
at the end of the day quit we're good
guys at the end of the day we always try
to do the right thing we help a lot of
people yeah behind the scenes yeah and
uh we'll never stop you never let that
stop and no as long as it does change
who you are I I I I think it' be easy
for me to be mean yes but I think you
look back and you go like I I will say
in the past 12 years we've basically
done nothing but try to make people
laugh whether it's on stage or here
failed maybe I failed a lot but you know
sometimes I got too serious when I was
feeling too serious but who all home
runs though life's boring for C and Home
Run sustain sustaining sustaining your
[__] yeah Kevin there are some people
home runs we're hitting singles baby you
still get in the Hall of Fame you're
telling me you and me aren't going to be
in the podcast Hall of Fame when they
make one I mean the first ever comic
athlete I was the per first professional
athlete ever to have a pod I I couldn't
agree we're on the Hall of Fame counts
on the podcast be surprised if we get
left out though cuz that'll be always
I'm not expecting
it it'll be people have beening
podcasting for 15 minutes and we'll be
left out but it's all good again it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter it's
all we're the ogs now uhhuh when we get
people in there like oh we you guys
inspir us I'm like oh my God I feel like
we've been doing it for four years we've
been doing it for about 13 hot second
about 13 Bubba I'm proud I'm proud oh me
too nothing more proud of outside my
kids this what we built for sure and I
have I'm still having we're still having
fun it's all right these things are
really distracting it's all right your
ears yeah they don't really like do
these look real do I look real do I look
like do I look like a
mantou oh dude I was at baseball with my
kid last night and that they have the
mound in the cages like the pitch Mound
and they're made out of heavy wood like
sturdy wood and it was on its side and I
was just going to move it cuz Tiger's
pitching now right I was going to move
it and boss was doing something so I
turned it fell on the top of my foot I
was 1,000% sure it cut my entire [__]
front of my foot off I went I fell on
the ground Tiger's laughing at first and
I was like no no no I I think I I think
it cut off my foot and he's like Daddy
I'm like oh I'm like take my shoe off
take my my toes this big right now oh no
it hurt so bad I don't think people like
why is your feet why is your feet why
they so sensitive why are they so
sensitive is it cuz we're cucks cuz cuz
we don't cuz like back in the day your
feet were strong but our feet are
sheltered Now by Nikes and cushioning
and air balances and air walks and my
buddy my buddy is an international
policeman whatever International
policeman that sounds like fake title
we'll leave it at that right he's he's
he said he showed me a video uh it was
in Fiji now fijians are Polynesian
people big big strong people like
Samoans and there was political strife
and they had a guy who was a political
opposition guy he was a big guy himself
tell me his this about his feet and he
was in
shorts and they were taking a bat they
were taking uh bats and and hard Hickory
uh ax handles to his feet they were
beating his feet the top of his he was
in the back of a pickup why they didn't
like him he was on the other side he was
on the oppos he was on the opposite uh
he was part of an oppos opposing
political party so they beat his feet
yeah and they were beating his feet and
you could see the pain he was in and
they were laughing these giant Samoan
guys giant fans were taking their their
these ax and bats oh [__] and you could
hear it go and I was like Jesus yeah I
didn't go through that it just kind of
fell on my top of my foot but if you
want to torture somebody you take a
rubber hose to the sole of their feet
they say you just whack the back bottom
of their feet they used to do that it's
weird feet are that sensitive cuz my
eyes are sensitive nuts are sensitive
like you hit the nuts nuts eyes and your
you know like like that that ankle bone
right there that ankle bone tender yeah
let me let me take a let me take a
[__] let me put some seel toad boots
on and kick you right there let me c so
people do say that when you get tattoos
like on your feet it's awful awful ribs
are tough the old feet yeah the feet are
tough is that my phone M out of all the
years I've been doing the very last this
why we're not giving me the Hall of Fame
by the way this weekend when you say
what am I doing for Christmas I'll be at
uh in right off the hook but I'm going
to in the middle of it I'm going to go
do um this uh crazy checkup and then I'm
going to go do some ready for this to
find crazy checkup they are you be home
are you going be home for Christmas you
piece of [__] no I'm going to be with my
my wife my my child and I'm going to be
with my wife's family in Florida cuz
I'll already be there what about the
other kids the other kids are going to
be with their grandparents who are from
Colorado but they'll be somewhere else
they'll be in in the mountains so um and
then but what I'm going to do while I'm
in Naples is I'm going daddy going Bor
hunt oh no off of I think airboats
that'd be cool yep you going Bor hun I
could have gone bow and arrow fishing
but that's that's be at night and I'm
doing stand up at night so then the next
day I'm getting in a chopper a
helicopter and then we're going to go uh
Gator
hunt so that should be interesting too
now you got to shoot Gators bring leges
with you well I could do that if he's if
he's down there he's right down there oh
he is I will I love was just hunting
Gators me to we're supposed to do a a
deer hunt somewhere down in leby Hunt
man yeah you guys kill things the best
but I I if I kill a gator it's going to
be I'm going to eat it I'm going to take
it to Virgina you're not I'm going to
take it to our boy boy I'm going it
nobody's listening it's just us you're
not eating in this me why not you're not
doing that I want some Gator meat no
one's eating Gat I'm not going to kill a
gator and not eat it no one's eating
gator people eat it all the time you're
not eating it you don't know I've eaten
Gator before I've had gator ribs have
you y and applesauce yeah you know what
tastes like just it's like n it's not as
good as a a pork rib orib I'm getting no
I'm I'm going to eat some Gator meat
they eat the tail really yeah Gator
tail so that's what I'm doing so you're
me Florida nothing is more anti-
Christmas than Florida mhm yeah it's hot
but Naples is nice than Christmas I've
been down there yeah but it's not all
the
not you know the best place you know the
most Christmas place on Earth
Chicago when I was there I was like oh
I'm Kevin mallister over New York yes
Chicago the entire city yeah is [__]
Christmas the vibe the weather I would
say uh Utah Salt Lake City is pretty
christmy I mean it's like families just
families walk in all Mormon right it's
Mormon but they're so Christmas Mormon
celebrate yeah they I think they do I
don't think joh Smith doesn't celebrate
Christmas yeah but I think Mormons do no
and they love it it's like the whole
town yeah special time to commemorate
the birth of Jesus yeah it's big I knew
that it's
big it's it's unbelievable like you'll
see like like Salt Lake City just
becomes this white it's super blonde
it's not just white white it's platinum
blonde white that's why Chicago whole
mix of the whole schmorgus board
Italian Jew white black not Jews but
yeah no there's there's there's a good
amount of Jews in Chicago yes but they
don't celebrate Christmas no they have
Eight Crazy Nights yeah but not
Christmas they still get into it they
celebrate
what okay Hanukkah well no I thought you
were saying on Christmas what they do
yeah they have Eight Crazy Nights but
does their eighth night end on Christmas
or no no I don't believe so Hanukkah
ended already mhm what yeah
mhm Chicago was so Christmas Even I was
there what 2 weeks ago that [__] was so
Christmas that's where you're from
Georgie y it's
[__] I feel like love Christmas not
as much as my lady my lady is just so
happy all the time when Dude white women
[__] love Christmas it gives them
something to do Mexican women love it
too though right Mexicans dig it my wife
digs all holidays yeah whole house is
all de she got these bro she got these
nutcrackers from uh
uh cost Cost Plus they're on some crazy
sale their last two they're supposed to
be so expensive they're literally bigger
than my kids you walk in the house
they're like protecting the DM right so
cute cool right check this out we had to
get this new car or whatever to fit the
kids in the guy car 15-year-old kid
carries this Nutcracker it's I don't
know 200 lb no I got it oh new
car right in the side of the thing and
he's 15 15 and he goes oh oh my God she
goes he starts crying my girl's like
what the [__] and the manager comes out
he's like oh my God and I so I goow up
they like no don't fire the kid it's not
his fault blah blah but they have to
they got car is two days old ah what
what the car took 12 weeks to come in oh
oh the entire Fender
G my girl calls me she goes cuz she
always [__] her cars up I go what
happened she goes you're going to be so
upset I'm like what happened she goes
those car told me yeah like 200b goes
yeah the employee at Cost Plus he he
dropped it on the car go how the [__]
you Dro it on he was just some young kid
and was
like holy [__] hilarious holy [__] also
hilarious though it's so funny it's out
of a movie
know I didn't have the string AK he he's
been there for like a week I told the
man like don't fire this isn't a big
deal we have to charge you though right
yeah
I'm gonna need those nutcrackers for
free at this point yeah I'm GNA need
those nutcrackers for on the house
yeah so the one out cracker has like a
[__] up eye now it hit the car that's
what you get what you get for messing
with my car the last two yeah I I'll
I'll I'll doll you up there do what do
you get your girl for Christmas um I got
her I can't say but I got her something
couple expensive things oh and you you
surpr you're the worst with gifts I just
can't give me that cool C machine that
one time yeah I did and it I gave it to
Stevie yeah well I went to your house
and it was up on top of the I was like
700 I was it was the most expensive
thing I owned at the time I lived in a
600t apartment in Marina del but I know
you really wanted I did you know I
bought you remember I bought you another
good gift I think you use it though what
your wife uses it what what' I get you
for your I think it was for with the
birth of tiger oh the quilt yeah yeah
Oher we yeah yeah that's a that's
Tiger's favorite yeah he uses that
non-stop no that was a legit gift legit
gift legit but you like capuccino so I
was like let me go ahead and get you I
didn't know how to use it and then you
were like appreciate you it it was a
basically a mantle piece at that come
back I'm like it's [__] but our boy
Stevie took it so it didn't go to way
Stevie used it to this day uhhuh I don't
do surprises I tell my girl especially
at this point I want car parts oh really
you get me a new gearbox you know which
gearbox I need for the lightning no no
so it's like don't waste the money you
you don't need and with her if I'm like
just tell me what you want where it's at
and I can't think of what I would want I
literally don't know what I what would I
want
um I don't I you don't like you're not
really into stuff no no there's nothing
you could steal from me where I'd be
like I don't know what the [__] I yeah
nothing do your parents go all out chin
do is it CU that what are you 45 46 bro
do your like my dad I don't get gifts
anymore we don't do gifts anymore we
didn't do it for a long time God that's
sad we know my brother and I give her
give them money but as far as like gifts
and stuff no I like a cashmere
sweater okay yeah all right well hope
you get that uh chin do you guys just so
you guys like my dad he was he was just
here he left yesterday he he gave me a
gift card which is cool that's what I
don't like so we give our parents money
right a a good amount of money and then
my mom will come over and visit amount
of money million
my brother makes a gazillion more
dollars than me so combined we're doing
20K for this year holy [__] but he takes
over I put in like a tiny that's cool
though that's good your the sons take
care of their parents my brother he's
the best he just yeah great has a lot of
money he good good damn 20K that what a
nice gift well it's your parents I wish
my
family so my parents will give my mom
put give us money after I was like
that's not the purpose please don't give
us any money we want you to spend the
money I know so yeah Georgie what's your
family do you guys all get together hey
[__] these handlers huh well they're for
the game look cool man damn it uh my
family we just like we chill uh stuff
was hard growing up so like some like
after my brother passed I had a really
awesome Christmas I got to go to WWE Raw
Stu like that that's a good GI but then
after that like it was more just helping
out the nieces like when I went I
dressed up as Santa Claus and had like I
went to the Dollar Tree and bought just
a ton of like cheap toys for them to
for the just so like Memories over gifts
you know I dig it and being Iranian you
guys kind of well we still celebrate it
you guys have your own holiday though
yeah like you know this dumb ass do you
know this they have their own holiday
bro you telling me about C the New
Year's yeah tell it's a Persian New Year
do you know about Persian New Year do I
know about Persian New Year he knows
know about pers New Year have I done
stand up and have I been asked to do
stand up on on to commemorate the
Persian New Year laugh Factory when is
it I don't know March first day spr
March 21st first day of spring first day
of spring but for Christmas yeah weele
we celebrate it we do Christmas um I get
the same gift from my dad every year
it's just gone up in price every year
since like I was younger what is it a
Disney Land pass what is the Persian New
Year I'm kidding I knew nothing about
the Persian New Year first day of spring
March it's what is it LO is it so Iran
goes off a different like Master Clock
it's not like 2023 there what is what
year are you guys they don't celebrate
the birth of Christ in other words well
it's a cultural holiday not a religious
one you know so that that's the big
distinction it has nothing to do with
religion it's just cultural but it's
like 13 days of visiting family and we
give gifts 13 better than the Jews they
have eight you get 13 yeah pretty cool
Christians will get one day yeah when
our Lord has risen a lot of stuff like
that oh no that's Easter Easter our Lord
is risen yeah he's born on Christmas
yeah even that's fake you know he wasn't
really born on Christmas it's all
completely made holiday bring it up
chin yeah he born on Christmas don't
know they don't they had to pick a time
they had to pick it they were just like
ah December 25th he really wasn't born
on there was noce DEC is not the date
mentioned in the Bible is the day of
Jesus's birth the Bible is actually
silent on the day or the time of year
when Mary was said to have given birth
to him in Bethlehem the early Christians
you know I went to Nazareth and I saw
where Mary you know allegedly gave birth
to Jesus and her house this the stone
structure is still there allegedly it's
pretty wild and they built a church on
top of it around it wild yeah it's
pretty
incredible the Bible is actually silent
on the day of the time of the year when
Mary was said to have given birth to him
so we don't know the year in which King
Herod died interesting then why did they
pick the 25th it's easy Christmas time I
don't know but oh let me look at Tim
Allen yeah I'm I'm already bored with
this topic I don't know why it's
Christmas yeah you're the Grinch dude
yeah I'm already like I suddenly
realized I was like I just don't care
about this so okay then Brian what's
your favorite Christmas
movie um I I would I should say It's a
Wonderful Life but but you know that's
what everybody says um I don't have one
come on I mean one that you don't mind
mention one I couldn't even like think
of one Home Alone Home Alone Santa Claus
Home Alone Home Alone Die Hard is not a
Christmas movie Die is Die Hard is a
great Christmas movie Die Hard is 100%
the best movie you're going to leave out
National Lampoon Christmas Vacation uh
National Lampoon Christmas Vacation is
phenomenal the best Christmas movie of
all time will watch it neither one of my
girl I love that movie oh it's such a
good movie what my absolute favorite I
worked with Beverly D'Angelo twice no
way oh yeah yeah way oh yeah no way
still sex yes way married to alucino
kids worked with them I don't want to
worked with her twice more than that I
worked with her on Entourage nightmare
that's cool you'll figure out uh
Nightmare Before Christmas that's
Universal though that's Halloween to
Christmas yep that's year round at my
house kiddos love that
movie Saw really anybody see the
triangle of
sadness I'm GNA pass on that man we're
talking about happy Christmas movies
it's a good funny movie yeah watch I
think you like called the triangle yeah
it's actually kind of astonishing anyone
watch the Torso killer documentary on
Hulu that's what I watched what you
never heard of the Torso killer oh buddy
what is that he doesn't want the fame
like everybody else cuz he don't want
his kids know how much of a piece of
[__] he was so he doesn't get the fame
but he killed so many women what did he
do with the torsos he would well no his
thing was he would cut their heads and
hands off oh my God damn but the Torso
killer doc on Hulu an any series
horrible human being he just killed all
serial killer and rapist who murder at
least 18 young women oh Jesus Christ
between 1967 and 198 but this
documentary this cop he's in a I think
he's a New Jersey or New uh New York cop
but he he was there's all no the the in
the documentary this cop was there's all
these cold case files and it's like it's
a serial killer man so he visits him
every day for 12 years and in 12 years
he gets one cold case solved and then it
opens up then they solve like six of
them so he inv visited the Torso killer
yeah he went and visited the Torso
killer and just sat down with him became
friends with him to get this in he
pretended to be his friend he hates him
but he pretended to be his friend to get
this information out of him and this guy
was like what are you going to do for me
and they started hooking him up giving
him his favorite pizza and [__] and he's
like it [__] sucks and the way he
talks about killings he's like how'd you
kill those two girls in the hotel man
that's crazy how would you get done he's
like you know I held him there for 3
days and we're actually friends and he
just like in his head he never takes
accountability he's like we're actually
friends we're having a good time they
didn't know I just fill up the bathtub
and put the one in the tub and sat on
her what and he's like what he's like
imagine the fair and the girl waiting
he's like yeah I know so I grabbed her
and I put her in the bathtub I sat on
her he's like you know they saw my face
I had to get rid of him man it's you
know it is what it and he's like I'm I'm
not I'm not like a creeper I didn't do
anything crazy with him but then they go
over the forensic dude he burn him with
cigarettes raped them multiple times cut
their heads off like terrible terrible
human being and then he does he's like
I'll give you this cold case information
to solve these crimes but you can't make
it public so that was the deal so they
would rush him to the courtroom and not
tell the Press cuz he didn't want it get
out to his kids he didn't want his kids
to know how bad of a person he was of
course the kids just Google their dad
like oh my God is it crazy [__] is so
weird
man yeah I'm into that seral so I I did
the guy I had the guy who solved Tupac's
murder um that cop LAPD guy I said what
got you into being a detective he said
well there was a serial killer who would
who was who would pick up young men who
were in the military base and he would
um yeah Greg kading uh real cool guy but
he he he solved a lot of murders and he
was you know Big Time homicide detective
and all that and he said he was a young
man and there was a there was a serial
killer there and he used to pick up guys
and he he he they'd be drunk come home
from the bar all soldiers yep and then
he'd say I got a sixpack you want a beer
I he taken it but he La the beer he Lac
the beer with uh you know some kind of a
sleeping he laced it with and then he
would torture them terribly and kill
them well he was hitchhiking when he was
15 and a guy picks him up the cop
hitchhiking yeah and a guy picks him up
and asks him if he wants a
beer and he was driving he was like 15
and he had to play I think baseball or
something he was like he's like I'm not
going to do that right now he wanted
wanted it but he's like I don't think
I'm going to do that he goes no I'm okay
the guy goes you sure I have a beer and
he goes no I'm all right I'm not I'm not
I actually can't but he remember the car
was this really cool hot rod he
remembered it very very well cars he he
said and I can't remember but it was
like this really cool GTO or something
yeah so then he's he is an older cop
this guy gets
caught
and all of the stuff that he did came
out and the car comes out and he went
saw the car he's like holy [__] he goes
that guy picked me up damn so he this
close but that's what got him into being
a detective that's cool yeah crazy he
almost died he almost got you know
almost cuz that guy was into doing some
really awful things too to people you
know to these men is it CRA like all
these hitch The Hitchhikers but the The
seral Killers all them like Ted Bundy
all the the Green River Killer the the
Hillside Strangler right up here in the
Hills here all of them depended on
hitchhikers who the [__] is is
hitchhiking back in the day I guess
people just did it all the time now
there's too much info out like you can't
hitchhike no but then Uber basically
hitchhiking I was going to say Uber
Uber's not hitchhiking you have you have
yeah you you know how to track it but a
form of hitchhiking you don't know who
the [__] you're jumping in with some
weirdo that's why they say always when
you get him like your cars for who like
Brendan to make sure cuz that that one
girl was killed she thought she was
getting a uber it was just a Ser killer
he's like get on in this is too easy oh
Jes Jump On In girl yeah that kind of
stuff is kind of nutty crazy good
Christmas talk everybody good Christmas
talk well there was that hor there was
that horror Christmas movie last year
from the guy who was in uh stranger
things the cop the Santa Claus one yeah
Silent Night yes it's called good
call damn good call girl but yeah that's
the that's the one s what the reason
horns and uh Christmas just go hand in
hand did you watch um did you watch the
Eagles lose to the Seahawks oh boy Bo
are in some trouble they are I lost
three in a row I picked the Eagles to
lose to the Seahawks Dallas is in some
trouble too D got they already clinched
a playoff spot but still they're not
looking good listen you know who's
balling the Rams oh no they only Lo they
only they're seven and seven eight and
seven now they've lost one game is in
double overtime the Baltimore raven
they're [__] no one's paying
attention to them they're balling right
now think they got like a 6 it was 58%
chance getting in you know football why
would if you've already clinch the
playoffs why in the world would you play
your starters in a game like that you
got to keep the momentum yeah what do
you mean you can't sit them cuz there
there has to be moment the teams that do
the best in the playoffs are the ones
that go into not the team that started
off 10-0 okay it's the team that was
like whatever three and five and then
they finally get some momentum they're
jelling you get into the playoffs hot
teams that do the best of teams that
start you want you want you want to get
those reps and you want home field
advantage home field advantage you want
to keep the momentum going if you sit
them you're going to lose that momentum
got it it's like in baseball Atlanta was
the hottest Team all year dominated
bounc out the first round in the
playoffs they went cold in the playoffs
damn they didn't play their starters
tired you get no they just they they get
out of rhythm they they just they lose
the sauce cuz that feels like the eagles
a little bit I mean it's a close game
they they got Chief ain't [__] this year
it's G to be a weird super bow it's
going be like Jacksonville no I i' I
predicted Niners Ravens did the Chiefs
lose in on Sunday no they won Patriots
they won they're still killing it
they're still doing great they're not
kill yeah but they're not killing the
same what are they 10 and
three I think they 10 and five 11 no 11
and 11 now 11 they lost they get their
ass who by the Broncos and five nine and
five they're nine and five so they're
not like but there's so many holes in
their game in their team they're not
going to go the Super Bowl not not the
Chiefs there's no team like the ners
right now God they're good they're
they're amazing man they're good and
they click on all cylinders you know I
mean well they didn't for three games
right the last three in a row games in
the beginning here's my argument a Super
Bowl team doesn't play like that in
December the Cowboys playing like that
right now it's not a good look at this
point in the year that's why Cowboys
always the Cowboys always St hot and was
like this is our year and then November
December comes and they they just they
get [__] it's [__] up Detroit's no
punk Detroit to I was hoping for the for
the Cowboys I thought the Cowboys would
I secretly root for the Cowboys for some
reason I D since I was a kid since I was
a kid I know my brother [__] hat like
Dak Shepard and Dak Prescott yeah yeah
that makes sense my brother actually
despises the Cowboys since I was a kid
because I grew up when they were EMT
Smith and darl Johnson and Nate noon I
love them I always see when they're
doing well it's it's like when Michigan
does well in college football you always
you that they need it's like when the
Yankees do well in baseball it's good
for the sport right but they're I don't
think there'll be [__] they'll make the
playoffs and get bounced out just like
every year speaking of Michigan there's
a big rumor that he might be the new
coach for the Chargers hargh oh we need
him I love him I love him bring him on
don't don't bring bich here get out of
here no bel's done yeah like go right
off into the sunset cut off seves you
know harb harb with the Chargers and
that quarterback we lose so many games
we La you loses so many games just off
coaching he's such a bad coach he got
fired they lost like 70 to zero and they
fired him I was watching that game I
guarantee this is his last game my
father-in-law was like no I guarantee
this the final was 63 to 21 at the end
but it was 63 to nothing for a while yes
for a while you just can't have it Sean
Peyton almost got fired in in Denver
when we got blown the [__] out just in
the NFL like
63 this isn't High School no no one gets
beat by 63 you know much money those
[__] are getting paid 63 you got to
tackle schmuck yeah you got to tackle
what else you got
chin current events Merry Christmas oh
how funny is that uh Flat Earth clip I
post of Rampage I told him cuz my team
cut it I sent to I go hey bud I'm going
to post this flat flat Earth one don't
read the comments yeah the Bible doesn't
say that the Earth is that was my one
question yeah there there's there read
up on that you'll see without getting
into detail also it doesn't matter what
the Bible says either the word the the
the uh I like Rampage very much he's not
I'm probably not going take my science
or religious advice from him but other
than that great guy great guy all right
first
one okay this one was pretty cool guys
this is some happy news this little baby
was swept up in a tornado cute but
landed perfectly fine oh he's exhausted
is that nuts probably in a little basket
or something he's so cute look at his
little face so cute chubby too he's
healthy God the four-year-old suck f up
by the Twister and like spun around he's
probably crying his [__] eyes out and
was exhausted from crying and then just
passed
out oh my
God that's terrible does anybody else
die in the house I don't think
so only one years
old my kids never cry there're such good
babies well I bet he's crying during
that tornado his shoulder dislocated
been on agon in 10 minutes I was trying
to get out he wasn't even
crying hey mom also keep going he was
lodged in a fallen tree about 30 feet
from where where the home one stood in a
tree oh I know want to tell they found
some crazy [__] have you ever seen where
they found like a rope that cuts right
through a tree or they found or they
find cows like seven miles Gone without
their skin ripped off you just e you
just cook them yeah literally skin no
their skin is not ripped off so what
happens the skin the force of it is so
bad that their skin literally gets
pulled off their body I'm serious no
and and you'll get like there was a
semi-trailer I think that was that was
like dropped on top of 100's old school
trucks just like seven miles down the
road tossed yeah but the the force is so
crazy that you'll get like literally a
rope that'll be embedded in a tree cuz
the speed goes crazy do you see Tony
Ferguson came out said he's no plan on
retiring yeah I expect that I expect him
to go out on his shield he's a warrior I
don't I bet they give him one more I
don't approve
but yeah what do you got Jen one more
and they're probably saying like this is
going to be a retirement fight no matter
what though right UFC isent off and get
know they should play his highlight clip
like they did they did for Korean zombie
you can do it for [__] Tony Ferguson
hell yeah send him out with a bang yeah
nothing against uh crean zombie but if
you're going to play that his whole
[__] walk out like Tony's done more
for the sport let's be real here he's a
[__] Legend yeah they one more a
winnable
fight soit we were talking about
something like this the other day right
come on man with parties and
whatever this gentleman thinks we should
replace the po pro bowl and wants it to
be an all black versus allh game instead
the only problem is there's no White
Corners there's no there's no White
Corners now offense defensive line and
quarterback and and running back we have
Christian mcaffry best player in the
league we're pretty set there we can
play we can go toe for toe toe for toe
when it goes defense offensive line
linebackers quarterback would
dominate unless you guys take Patrick
Mahomes that's weird uh he's half so
we're have to figure that out we have to
do we have to do a lottery there pick uh
receivers going to be well we have CP
who's the best receiver in the league
too is he actually the best receiver in
the league oh buba his season two years
ago is the best ever over Tyreek H oh
all day I'll take I'll take C oh all day
more reliable yeah he's just been
injured this year but as far as
skill-wise all day
agree to disagree yeah but we we the
thing is this is close than you
think no so he put I'm sick of average
white guys commentating on football
average you mean uh which which one's
average yeah do you mean Tony Romo yeah
Well's not average uh Payton Manning uh
Tom Brady's gonna do it best player of
all time if I remember Steve Young's
pretty good Phil Sims Hall of Famer
Boomer cison Hall of Famer Yeah Tim TBO
best college football player ever yep he
commentates so I don't know about that
but this is also not a good idea no this
is divisive and shitty i' also like to
see it because I think you'd be
surprised what I like about sports
though what I love about sports L
brother and white together dude line up
the wat brothers who are savages how
about our boy who you want to get the
boas riled up in a race war you want to
fire up the boas let's not talk about
that in a race war no no no no no
there's no race war this is not the
problem is we don't have any Corner we
have no secondary no listen we have good
we have Jason seahorn you bring him out
of retirement we be we have no corners
it's going Corners Corner position
receiver will be okay quarterback would
dominate offens line
dominate just all you're going to do TI
end you mean wi you don't have any white
guys are going to you mean why you got
no white guys strong side white side no
white guys can cover DK M GAF no white
guys can cover tyriek Mill no white guys
in the league no black guy can cover
coupe not happening well yeah but but
you're GNA have you're going to have
Tyreek R Tyreek post and he's just going
to run and they they're just going to
nobody's going to keep up with him he's
just going to catch every football every
all right if you want to do this and
then
coaching I don't like this I don't want
to go down I didn't bring this up but
you want to start coaching football's
great brought it up football and sports
have done more to bring races together
and kill the M yeah but everything's
about race let's talk about coaching
this is one guy offense defense
coordinator this is Rashard menahal
menal yeah but people are running with
it now but
so what is what was Rashard a wide
receiver he was he
was we get we we'd get cooked at corner
not going to lie that's JJ watt's uh
comment nobody on our Squad is cover
Tyreek Hill he had yeah it's going to be
tough certain positions can be tough but
again who's going the
plays brand who's your coach calling the
place name somebody you name uh White
coaches where do I start I want to hear
it oh we can start with Don schula we
can start with the great 49ers coach we
start with Jimmy Johnson we start with
Nick sain we start with belich go go to
the black coaches parcel go name one I
actually think Tom Tom I think the
Steelers the Pittsburgh Steelers coach
okay keep going yeah he's great I don't
want to anymore he's
great this this just means that like
look I I didn't start this but if we're
if you're going to get into it like that
Pittsburgh coach is good right what's
the record Thomason I don't even know at
this point but they're
good they're seven 10 years ago be let's
take a little break take a break it's
Christmas time you know that means it's
time for some NCAA football bowl games
baby want to make money and watch all
these cool you got the BCS b games
coming up January 1 1st you got Alabama
you got Washington you got freaking
Michigan and you got Texas there's so
much to bet on and make Bank bro do it
with draftking Sportsbook you make every
play count new customers can score 150
instantly in bonus bets just for betting
$5 on college football all right
download the app right now use the code
fighter new customers score 150
instantly in bonus bets for betting just
five bucks on college football only on
draftking Sportsbook with the code
Fighter the crown is yours gambling
problem call 1800 Gambler or visit ww
1800 gambler. net New York call 8 778
hope NY or text Hope ny4
67369 in Connecticut help is available
for problem gambling call
n7777b dog please play responsibly on
behalf of booill Cena when resorts in
Kansas 21 plus age varies by
jurisdiction avoid an Ontario bonus bets
expire 168 hours after issuance cdk
ng.com MMA for eligibility and deposit
restrictions terms and responsible
gaming resource
dude you know what the best gift is
what's that macadamia
nuts buttery healthy Omega 7 fat nuts
are great stocking stuffers I don't have
that kind of money dude it's so
expensive I don't have that's why House
of macademia got you covered dude they
give it to you at a pretty nice price
you know what's even better to give this
holiday season a gallon of macadamia
nutmilk gon a gallon of nut milk wait
what I do what am I going to do I put it
all over my body I mean I mean I like I
like my coffee that's all I care does it
go with coffee that's what I care about
that's what you do with it I can't I
don't want to go into this dairy stuff
and that's right get a gallon free
gallon of macadamia milk when you visit
House of macadamias
docomo to your cart with any products
use the code TFK you get a gallon of
macademia nut milk you can get those
chocolate cover macadamias the 45%
macadamia nut bars all of it's fantastic
House of macadamias
docomo your cart with any products use
the code TFK at House of macademia
can we spark up the what [__] the
Shanahan what he started what Mike
Shanahan started name a coach dude
they're all under his toage that might
Green Bay Packers Kyle Shan 49ers best
team in the league right that'll change
that's going to change the Miami
Dolphins best team in the league all
under Shanahan that is true yeah you
Shanah one of the greatest get into it
you you who's going to call the plays
who's going to carry the boats you piece
of [__] I think there are plenty of
black I know but I'll wait name them
well there are some offensive
coordinators and defensive coordinat
name you get Eric bmy nightmare who else
you going to get look I'm not I'm not
going to get into this conversation you
don't want to no I'm saying that I don't
like I don't like an all white all black
game I don't I didn't start the game I
don't want to see it
but Rashard said it the bottom line is I
think I think you got to put your money
for one reason one reason only you're
going to it's going to be a close game
but at the end of the day nobody covers
your back field you don't have the white
players call the field well I would
players are I would do this watch watch
the plays this is all it is you drop
back Tony dun you drop back Tony D you
drop claim Tony J dun's half white I
don't think he is look it up you drop
back and Tyreek and DJ just run out and
just catch the ball oh yeah cuz cuz the
the NFL because so easy to do that
against NFL caliber defensive single ter
was also a good coach Mike single was
actually he really wasn't single look
how far we're going Mike single
I knew I was thinking about single
compared
to I think he lasted
two look it doesn't matter I don't want
to get into this conversation you can
get it hey chin yeah name name the race
the only undefeated coach of all time
what race was he his name's Don schula
for the Miami Dolphins 72 Dolphins
undefeated it's never happened ever
again who got closest weird bellich this
is a bad conversation we're not going to
talk about white versus black in
coaching well this dude wants to strike
a lot of it a lot of his white coaches
you know back then you were never going
to have a black coach who was allowed oh
here you go there it goes there it goes
um there there it is there it is yeah
that's the problem it was what it was
you're a [__]
Shield I'm not I keep it real I keep it
real like they just didn't have the
opportunity well they do now they have
to interview well they will they will
have they will have you'll have some why
is the it just takes some time
sure listen to
him is that your answer is that your
answer you ask stupid
question Al Bowen doesn't shy down does
he I love Al bow I don't think he should
be getting this aggressive after what's
you know recently but he's sick of
people's [__] and that guy goes that guy
goes you have a failing career too so he
he he offended him he still too look at
that Al Baldwin killed Alec Baldwin
killed a guy he
did that guy [__] with Al Bal is a
loser yeah that's but that's why he's
doing it that's why he's filming get the
[__] re dumb camera never been had his
ass kicked you see what that guy looks
like with his dumb mullet and his stupid
[__] that's what bothered me the most
is like that's why I wanted get the [__]
out of his you can't hold Alec Baldwin's
jock yeah he's [__] zero silly
talented yeah
yeah but you know Alex Baldwin you know
with the whole Trump remember he was
making fun of trump so you get a lot of
hate for that then his wife asking him
to follow on Instagram I've listened to
yeah I've listen to Al he's not as
liberal as people think he's just not
he's an old school kind of democrat all
right [__] off what's this J this is
Matt riddle I love Matt riddle so I'm a
big WWE Fan I only know Matt from okay I
only know Matt from WWE and I totally
forgot that you know he's a UFC fighter
no I forgot on Ultimate Fighter he's a
star well he apparently wants to go back
in and give it another round I bet they
would do it because he's a massive star
now he's he's one of those guys who he
had Talent they just kind of screwed him
over then goes WWE becomes a massive
star over there I bet the UFC would
welcome with open arms who would he be
fighting who I don't know what weight
class is cuz clearly they weren't
testing in the WWE so it's going to be a
little different story there was neither
is the UFC a big boy no he's not a big
boy he's heavyweight though right now
Matt's getting a lot of attention from
bear knuckle what' you say right now
bear knuckle and I could see him going
that I could see him going to one pfl I
would sign him especially with the Jake
Paul Logan Paul WWE vibe there but uh
Dana doesn't have a good history with
Matt he no Matt went off on Dana yeah oh
over what they cut him and then Matt
went to WWE and got super famous oh and
Dana doesn't like that he wants you to
you know suffer but now WWE and Dana are
one so someone the W I don't know his
relationship with W I'm sure someone at
WWE was going to like sign this kid he
just got fired from WWE okay so he's
burned both Bridges listen it's going to
be a very tough comeback but there's pfl
there's one Championship there's beer
knuckle there's gamebred MMA he go to
gamebred like he's a massive star he
went off at a airline for uh sexually
assaulting him when they patted him down
oh okay so he was just having a bad day
I think okay but he's a superstar so
much Charisma athletic kid can fight
someone's going to sign him this time
you're hearing about him right he he was
on Ultimate fighter like stud stud on
not on your season you're saying I was a
heavyweight he I think he fought at 55
it says uh welterweight then uh
middleweight and right currently he's
like a 216 right now
so yeah is that from is that from
seral is that him he's a super he's got
a cool little stick he's got a good body
man kids no they tried burying him yeah
and then he went on WWE and became a
superstar so I doubt the UFC signed him
if he did that the the WWE to but dude
be not he'd be a massive his fan base
with WWE with the WWE fan base and beer
knuckle uh game bread MMA pfl one
Championship like he has a huge career
if he wants it people love him I he's
one of my faves anybody who gets [__]
over by the UFC and goes on to do stuff
like your boy I love look at that
mushroom that's a cool tattoo he's got a
mushroom tattoo he's a stud man he was a
fan favorite on the show body I like his
body I'm I'm happy body athl dude can
fight and athletic too and now he has
the fan base dude I don't know why you
wouldn't sign him probably one of the
biggest free agents in a hot I'll
[__] sign him hell yeah I want to be
built like that I like his body I'm very
happy with
it you guys want to touch on Donald
Trump in Colorado yeah I don't care I'll
explain it if anybody want I don't want
this podcast to come to screeching Hal
okay we move on
to it's a [__] thing that they that
the federal Supreme Court they're doing
whatever they can make sure he become
president even though if he gets voted
in then they know it's looking that way
so they're saying he's an
insurrectionist and he hasn't even been
convicted in court it's so ridiculous
they're so dumb that Supreme Court is so
Supreme Court's going to eat it alive
it's not going to so dumb what is this
CH [__] study come up recently by
Lending Tree who's Lending Tree hold on
while specific Auto Brands don't make
people worse drivers it seems to be true
that certain types of drivers gravitate
toward different makes and models a
recent study from found D some Brands
more accidents du and other citations
Ram drivers are were the worst because
they're cucks and no no how funny is
this the 10 car brands with the most
driving in incidences in the study
number one ram I drive that number two
Tesla only Tesla and Subaru came close
but check out what they said
specifically about Ram right here the
guys the big dicks R Ram D had more
speeding incidents than all the brands
and said that the Ram 1500 quickel
where's the noise part though I don't
know so the ram 1500's quick
acceleration played a role it sounds
like manly [__] like you drive too fast
and you accelerate too hard oh no don't
give me a ticket who wrote that their
moms like shut
up yeah I thought that'd be fun for
brenon I need to get a car that where my
my shin the muscle the repetitive injury
from doing this constantly is [__] me
up
accelerating yeah I mean it doesn't get
any gayer than a test Tesla do you
barely doesn't it have the automatic
pilot [__] yeah there's no car that you
that you can get that's not gay that you
don't have to do this you get a stick
shift which is super manly which not for
you all right you're it's not going to
work for you're going to have to use
both pedals yeah right the clutch and
the gas all I know is Selen Diaz has
stiff person's disease and she has no
control over Dion Selen Dion the [__] is
Selen Diaz Dion That's What I Meen Dion
Dion I meant howon Diaz anden how bad is
that though you can't move your muscles
it's very sad yeah it's very sad you
guys she's this Amanda bid doing a
podcast she started podcast keeping it
alive she can't I want you to see her
video she can't decide what she wants to
do one day she wants it one day she
doesn't Amanda bind Amanda bind so she
wanted to get like Drake and Jack harlon
so she couldn't get that so she did one
episode then said the podcast is on
pause for now yeah I get it but is a
nightmare now she's back but check out
how she talks here and it's kind of
scary she's out of the rehab or whatever
yeah I think so so I wanted to post
something about how I felt last night
after I made a post that we were pausing
the podcast um I felt really sad and I
was like in a really bad mood because
the podcast was actually something that
I was really looking forward to filming
next week and it was something that I
was really happy and excited about so I
talked to a few friends and they all
said to keep going so we're going to
continue the podcast and we are filming
next Friday as planned I think that
podcast just take time to grow like to
build a following so I shouldn't have
said what I said last night about like
not getting the type of guests that we
were looking forward to getting because
you never get them in the future yeah
it's tough lady we know it 13 years we
can't get Drake to call us back she just
seems like a robot now it's yeah well
that's a lot of her face isn't moving so
she starting a podcast I'm have Drake
postone J Carlo on you have trouble
getting them that's crazy that's a lot
of filler though guys that's why her
face looks weird that's the least of her
problems but what is she I I thought
Amanda bin was an actress she was she
was a Nickelodeon kid all that yeah
Nickelodeon little she was massive what
is she now that she's not a singer no
she graduated from
fitm there's she she she had to go to
rehab she she has some substance abuse
issues she has a tattoo on her face bro
wait so Fame early early childhood Fame
doesn't solve all your problems can you
imagine being a parent and your kid gets
famous you like oh [__] oh yeah the
money nice but heavy lies the ground
there's I'm writing this joke about that
it's like you know in a way if your kid
has never flown commercially like the
Kids the super rich you should probably
be arrested for child abuse cuz it's not
going to work out for that kid if your
kid has a Tik Tok under 10 you had some
problems yeah so Amanda Biden started
that pod and was like I want Drake bu
and Jack harlo and those three she's not
right abely not she's not right in mind
um I'm pretty sure you grew up with this
Jennifer Love huitt I know I did she was
like super hot tits yeah met her a
couple times talking about those tits
Chen I'm talking about those tits and
face her her her main one was I Know
What You Did Last Summer and what was
the oh and then she was in that that
that was one of my favorites no but she
was in that show uh famous show in the
9sek no uh what was it called oh where
they lost their parents yeah yeah Party
of Five I think Party Party of Five no
but where huge show where was she when
she had those huge tits um what
showere yeah she got very small hands I
met her a couple times very tiny hands
you know her yeah so you how you're gay
I shook her hands very you saw her like
she has tiny hands small hands my friend
director her in the movie yeah cuz all
the skins in them tits all right dude
right I don't know man well so people
are saying that uh she looks
unrecognizable now and then I'll show
you her picture that she's reading the
[__] internet which is remember this
this is a look that we remember right
yeah she's so this is her this is her
Instagram right now so this is her I
think the latest post good morning happy
holidays she from
hooville all right she does and hille
sometimes just had some stuff done it'll
your I think the prom is the fillers
it's toughed for a woman in Hollywood is
I'm not looking at
that I'm not spot on dude yeah another
one for the be it is hard for women in
this business God damn the internet
hates you she's still hot she looks
pretty I'm just saying that she just
looks like it's not her
her see her eyebrows she adits to using
filters too so it's like a combination
of filters and some other stuff did the
body give up or what no no no oh let's
see it's just that there's a lot of um
no she's still super pretty she's got a
little lip work B no one say anything
about her prettiness it's just she looks
like a different person yeah oh she
doesn't look like she looked when she
was 17 that's why she's using age as a
thing but they're not saying that she
doesn't she looks old but also people
want to hate on Hollywood like go when
they get older and they I quit getting
rolls yeah yeah yeah yeah it's like
you're an aging NFL player and another
younger player comes in takes your gig
you guys are losing no one's saying
about her age saying because she's old
she can't get rolls dudey it is true
that you aren't going you're they
Hollywood is ruthless it's ruthless but
that's it with anything you can't be a
president be 80 like Biden it doesn't
work out dude you age
out she looks great though she's
crushing it
mhm all right want some animal on always
some animal ones real quick this is a
near pal veres hell yeah wild I'll show
you this real quick killer wh headbutts
of dolphin yeah so San Diego area no
it's isn't that here no it's right here
what CH it's right off of near is up
there Beach Palace from oh from Palace
Verdes to San Diego so they're swimming
from here here to there it's kind of far
W it's a long and they followed him the
whole
way turn off the music and you'll see
want to mess with killer whales they
will eat
dolphins just tosses up in the air dud
they just killer whales are asshol yeah
so they're actually messing with their
food right now and they're going to eat
them afterwards yeah they want to get
them out of there they'll eat
them well you don't want to be near a
dolphin either trying to get away from
that giant that's got to
suck but the Dolphins so much quicker
they're not they're just not they are
though they're probably not smarter
though this was not that great those
just head but but you don't want to be
near it do Open Water this is in South
Africa they saw a giant eagle eating a
Impala our very eyes that's a huge bird
on a golf course has killed an Impala
that's an Impala
unreal kill them look at the size of
those [__] tows they said it's a a
marshall eagle and they have like a up
to close to eight Wing or 8ot wingspan
yeah it's called Death from the sky
there's even bigger Eagles I had to
Google it there's a bigger eag than that
thing this one's like 18 lb there's some
that are like 48b no how many golden
eagle is not that big bald eagle is
definitely not that big no the golden
eagle really big the harpy eagle but
they're not that heavy 40 lbs you how
big of a bird that is in the sky no way
a let me
see no I saw 48 PB somewhere largest
eagle by weight the Stellar Sea Eagle
ain't [__] [__] that ain't [__] CH 20
PBS though that'll they they'll pick
that ain't [__] dude
that thing looks rocking giant
Philippine
eagle or maybe I misread 20 PBS ain't
[__] 20 pound's still a big old bird a
big old bird cuz they're Hollow yeah
that's a big old bird yeah I don't [__]
with birds man they got crazy Claws and
all that trash that you see out front
when you walk in if there's trash it's a
bird it's i i w I sit there and watch
cuz I was like who's throwing the trash
around the studio yeah it's a black
crow who the there's that might and Mike
dika there was a story about um Rosie
GRE Rosie gre's talking about how I
think it was
like some famous tough guy football
player giant guy and there was a police
dog it was I think it was like a big
game playoff game they had a cop who had
a police dog he was just staring at that
dog and he goes what are you looking at
and he
goes it's a police dog he goes yeah he
goes I kill that dog he goes how' you do
it he goes I'll bite it
back
wild man you think you kill a dog police
dog I don't think so what's this chin uh
last one Georg weird story huh yeah it
didn't really go anywhere yeah so this
this is a little prank that these kids
played on their Grandma by showing them
Grand the auto5 and telling her it's the
real news dude this is a this is a prank
I play on my followers when I post
videos of a TRX jumping over I thought
it was real I was like I was like brenon
I didn't know what you were posted I
didn't know you posted it and I was I
looked at I go I got to show brenon this
everyone think it's real and then the
best was it said 100% real I put this is
absolutely 100% I was like I I was like
wait this is crazy look people tag me
and be like dude look at this TRX it's
nuts I'm like okay dude okay let me see
this this is
hilarious oh my God
no oh my God no way those Graphics look
awful
know oh my oh my God
it's not nice that's hilarious oh you
could do that to basally any grandma
though God that's
crazy yeah I saw I was watching a crash
tests and then they had these cars that
were hit in this pole and just peeling
and I was like holy [__] when when do
they do these crash tests I looked at a
little closer and I was like I told you
how was it Madden the football game like
I tell people the story like there's no
you're full of [__] I'm like I'm telling
you Brian's stupid I I at first it took
me a second mad was an actual game it
took me a second cuz I was like wait and
then I saw uh Andy Reed and I was like
Andy's not that skinny I thought God
damn it he's moving all stiff like I
told Chris that he's like that's not
true you're making that I'm telling you
Brian was watching mad think he's
watching a real 30 seconds I got taken
in but still but for the story it's two
hours yeah but if you're far back like
is that yeah that's what it was I was
far I was like watching it on a small
thing is that it chin that's it hey kids
kid Comedy Club let's go this weekend
Thursday Friday Saturday on Comedy Zone
and then I got Mike drop San Diego
January four five and six oh
[__] it be fun San Diego yeah I always
need reason go to San Diego fing town
maybe I'll jump up there love that come
down you get some reps in January that'
be great all right buddy we'll figure it
out you and me together dude [__] slap
our [__] together on stage yes slap um
the Toontown just got released project
lightning episode one is out now go
watch on two toown right now and then as
far as standup I'm in Nashville January
25th one night only Austin Texas January
26 27th I'll be in Austin on January
20th during the fight campaign with Mr
Joe Rogan as well for uh Strickland
versus dupes um but yeah stand up you
got January 25th Nashville Austin 26
27th go watch Toontown with the
lightning it's the fun one now the fun
begins too so all right kids love you go
see Brian and Naples you Christmas
bastards yeah love you guys we're
out this isn't a pouch this is a pouch
what's up guys if you're like me I used
to use white nicotine pouches all the
time non-stop whatever it was if you saw
me on podcast your boy had it in if you
saw me on stage I had it in if I'm at
the gym I had nicotine in my mouth at
all times and then I found black Buffalo
they make the same great flavors that
you know we're talking about mint winter
green they got my favorite the straight
and they're all tobacco free that means
no tobacco stem or Leaf is in these and
they're made in the US OFA us OFA
product so you know it's good it's black
Buffalo so if you're 21 or older and you
use nicotine or tobacco head on over to
Black Buffalo that's
blackboom